[Music]
for example i don't know why this one
didn't sell but it's called classic
pinup girls of the taliban
and there they
are time
it just didn't go over well this one
is a good time
hooray
[Laughter]
this one uh is a coffee table book that
uh stars vladimir putin yes the uh
russian leader yeah it's called putin on
the glitch oh
it's him just
all his bling
flashy bladder
it's flashy vladimir putin
[Applause]
he doesn't seem he doesn't seem very
happy about it look over here the other
one he doesn't seem thrilled about it no
he doesn't that is not the way someone
dressed like that usually well i think
he's probably pretty humble yeah
probably you know what i am eddie i'm a
history buff oh really i love american
history you sure do and this one is a a
great book it's called founding fathers
in feet pajamas
the founding fathers of our nation
[Applause]
working on the declaration of
independence and you got to see late
into the wee hours yeah and there's
george washington oh george
i don't know what's wrong with you guys
but he still has a sword though
he's in his speedy pajamas but he has a
sword in case
just in case somebody says anything
about it pajamas case trouble breaks out
he was also like six two and in this
depiction he's this little boy i don't
quite get it that's what you're gonna
pick on yeah that's me
i'm sorry that's not historically
accurate he was much taller than you
depict him in footy pajamas
you uh
you found the flaw with me
i love this one i love this next book
yeah it's called badasses in balloons
these are badasses
[Applause]
say hello to my little friends
and my hot air balloon
and my gentle way of transporting
myself he's a cocaine czar who has a
balloon and then look at these guys on
the back i just love hi
danny trejo danny trejo and there's
robocop and freddy krueger
they're just out for a nice time
you know a friendly friendly party
this one's called face tattoos on people
who would never get face
it looks tattoos actually
and then uh this is the thinnest of all
the books so thin right here you barely
see it it's just two pages it's the
complete encyclopedia of male irish porn
stars
that's pretty much it that guy
and there's this
oh boy
which one do you prefer
ladies you want to be with this guy
or this guy
or this guy
or this guy
yes eisenhower i'm not irish
all right
and finally finally ladies and gentlemen
the best the best of all the books i'll
put money on this book i don't know why
this didn't sell right this should be
number one on the new york times
bestseller every family's coffee table
everyone's going to get it after i
promote it here it is ladies and
gentlemen gentlemen
a second little drinker
animals on meth there it is
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh there's more they're not as good as a
oh come on why not who cares
yeah
and then
yeah you get the idea
they start to get to be a bummer
we've always got the kitty
[Applause]